believe I know but I don't understand
why I mean I've been paying my rent
every I know you've been paying the rent
every month we're that's enough no I've
been making my rent every month what
about my rent no oh that might be the
problem
yeah could be that I'm gonna try to
figure it out okay I didn't think I had
to clarify that she should be paying
rents I actually need a place to you do
yeah I mean ever since Tiffany moved out
any time I see something that reminds me
of her I just like lose focus for 40
minutes you really miss her huh I miss
living with people and I hate living in
the dorms Bridget said she was looking
for a new place too so maybe the three
of us can look together I would not mind
that I love Bridget she's awesome
you do love Bridget no never mind you
can't lower the crush it's it's not it's
not a thing it'll be fine it's not like
we're gonna be living in the same room
they're not going on with a girl you
have a crush on that's never worked out
ever let me fine I'm just gonna talk to
her and we'll figure it out okay okay
okay yeah you should they love together
hardwood floors
great location do you know about the
circuit oh yeah we good SEO okay this
will be perfect for you then yeah it's
gorgeous but this does have three
bedrooms do you do you have another
looming we can find
I think we should do it we can't even
afford this place with three roommates
yeah but what if we get a fourth
roommate we can double up one of the
bedrooms this really is a great deal
come on how hard can it be to find two
roommates I parked this two to three
hours a day oh this one is my favorite
so why are you moving out of your
current living situation
you guys smoke weed yeah we do yeah
sweet gas math math you guys like
climbing trees Hey hi it's been a minute
yeah have you been good I'm moving out
of the frat so there's that
that's cool I think that'll be really
good for you do you think this is a good
idea
hey you're the one who said we were
friends right yeah you're right okay
cool well I guess um I guess well let
you know
cool thank you see n Elliot so that was
weird
yeah I know we hooked up one but it's
not a big deal I think he's probably the
best person we've met somebody told me I
can't remember who that you shouldn't
live with your crushes okay okay okay
but Elliot is not a crash like I had
just broken up with Jack it meant
nothing to be completely honest I do
kind of like Elliot so I think that he's
so great right yeah let's see let's
Goodman here okay awesome so now we just
need one more person
you know it's me Madison and it's me
Stacy thank you for coming by thank you
great well the doors right over there
and I'm very ready I will do that when
I'm ready
oh god that was a disaster
I mean I don't know what we should do
should we post something on Craigslist
I could tell Bridget that we are gonna
have an open house and she should be
here at 3:30 oh can I come in June said
that there was a room available occur
yes June said we had no but house well
we actually don't know if that rooms
available anymore
so oh well um you know what if you don't
live with me it's totally fine I can
find somewhere else I really I do want
to live with you um it's just that
Elliott already agreed to take that room
yes but Madison didn't we say that the
situations between Bridget and Elliott
are so similar that they should both
have an equal chance at getting this
place Gina the rooms are you big and
maybe we could share it yeah you two
could share it we could share it
yeah because of what we talked about
earlier right about your hygiene problem
right right all right and of course uh
we do want to keep rent low for everyone
so maybe another roommate isn't about ID
I'll come I'll show you the room right
now and June you know after this I would
love to have a chat with you about that
time warner built absolutely after I
take my fifth shower because I am clean
right here this is a bad idea you know
it okay I'm sorry if you are
uncomfortable with it we don't have to
it just looks nice everyone we met so
idea okay maybe if we lived
won't even see her that much anyway are
you sure yeah you have to get over her I
mean she's straight
yeah and what better way to get over a
crush than to learn way too much about
them totally I mean like I can't like
Elliott affected her but you know no
okay so we're doing this let's do it oh
this is good this is a good idea yeah
yeah yeah this is great okay let's do it
yes I love it hey y'all move in pretty
much you need help with anything um I'm
okay just uh let me know be right here
Yeah right there cool yeah I mean it
sucks at Madison comp living here but
yeah there were like 17 cats living in
here before from the previous event well
I love cats oh I wouldn't have minded
that yeah I just wish that I could
afford my own room this is gonna be
really fun
I am super easy to live with I swear I
talk in my sleep well this is she kind
of cute I I'm gonna take a shower
oh okay um yep you uh do that tell me
all the water pressure is